[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique lendemain d'élections
présidentielles emmanuel macron a été
réélu avec 58 et demi pour cent des voix
face à marine le pen épilogue d'une
campagne atypique dans un contexte
national assez tendu un contexte
international lui dramatique et
maintenant tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que la défiance est forte lisible
dans niveau élevé d'abstention et de
vote blanc quelle leçon politique va en
tirer emmanuel macron évidemment c'est
très attendu en aura des signaux dans
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
au plus tard sans doute le 13 mai notre
invité bonsoir à médine manche alain
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes ministre la transformation et
de la fonction publique
que faut-il faire en priorité vous
répondrai à toutes les questions tout à
l'heure de brigitte boucher tam traduit
les oppositions veulent prendre leur
revanche aux législatives d2 et 19 juin
c'est ti frère qui viendra vous en
parler et puis mon petit doigt me dit
que la question d'actu de vincent roux
vous intéressera ce sera dans un quart
d'heure mais d'abord vous amélie de
montchanin vous êtes au gouvernement
vous faites vos cartons en ce moment on
continue à travailler
on a pris l'engagement de travailler
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure et donc
il ya encore un conseil d'ami cette
semaine et puis surtout ça fait des
semaines qu'on travaille pour que le
projet du président puisse se mettre en
oeuvre le plus rapidement possible
ensuite donc je voudrais un exemple les
quelques jours on a augmenté lundi ce
minimum de traitement c'est le smic de
la fonction publique on travaille aussi
pour préparer le dégel du point d'indicé
on travaille aussi sur les retraites de
tout cela on va en parler mais quand
même il va y avoir un remaniement
évidemment un premier gouvernement de
macron de si je puis dire dans la liste
des ministres il pourrait être maintenu
ou promu il ya bruno le maire darmanin
il habite bornes gabriela talent et à
vous on vous cite aussi comme pouvant
rester au gouvernement vous êtes au
courant ce que je sais qu un nouveau
gouvernement oui mais ça faisait 10
j'avais affaire à faire des choix avec
un premier ministre qu'il aura à choisir
et on voit bien que l'enjeu devant nous
c'est quoi c'est d'avoir un gouvernement
qui est capable de rassembler les
français d'unir le pays d'avancer vite
pour voir des résultats et de mettre en
oeuvre ce projet après je vais dire
comme elisabeth bornes il ya des sujets
il ya des questions qui ne se pose pas
aujourd'hui pour nous les questions
elles sont pour ceux qui prennent les
décisions qui doivent composer son
gouvernement moi je suis envoyé au fond
je finis une campagne pour le président
et se prépare déjà une campagne pour les
législatives
c'est ça mes objectifs c'est ça là où je
me concentre on est dans l'action dans
une période particulière ça la période
de transition où il ya quand même une
forme d'un confort des ministres qui se
demandent s'ils vont rester ou pas c'est
la règle vous ne ferez pas dire le
contraire vous vous avez envie de rester
et c'est pas en train de vous lorsque
vous y aider tout j'ai envie que ce
projet réussisse juillet portés et dont
tu apportes je vais porter sur les
marchés j'étais convaincre les français
et donc donc j'ai envie qu'ils
réussissent j'ai envie qu'ils
réussissent avec un gouvernement qui
peut agir j'ai envie qu'ils réussissent
avec une majorité qui puisse agir donc
voyez moi je suis élu de l'essonne j'ai
envie que ce projet réussisse dans le
territoire où j'ai été élu il ya cinq
ans donc oui ça fait déjà beaucoup de
choses à faire oui bon c'est pas mal
d'être ministre quand on est utile avec
la passion que vous avez de la fonction
publique donc vous aimeriez autant
rester c'est ce qu'on comprend emmanuel
macron avait nommé un premier ministre
de droite edouard philippe en 2017 après
avoir fait l'analyse du scrutin qui
l'avait porté à l'elysée cette fois
c'est l'électorat de droite qui
majoritairement le porte le maintien à
l'elysée et il ya une partie de la
gauche effectivement qui méfiante à son
égard est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils nomment pour rassembler pour
réconcilier vous l'avais dit au premier
ministre de gauche alors première chose
je vais vous répondrai simplement ma
première conviction c'est qu'il faut
qu'on arrête collectivement tout cas
c'est ma conviction de segmenter les
français comme si vous et du marketing
nous on fait de la politique au sens
noble du terme on cherche la bordée des
solutions aux français est donc le
premier ministre que le président on
choisira il le choisira je pense parce
que d'abord il ya des compétences parce
qu'il pourra réunir le pays parce qu'il
pourra tenir le gouvernement et savoir
si son étiquette est comme ci ou comme
ça c'est au fond remettent les français
dans des cases
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes
politiques jouent à ce jeu là je pense
est un jeu dangereux parce que les
français ne s'y retrouve pas ce qui est
un jeu non pas dangereux mais qui fait
perdre du temps c'est quand même la
langue de bois parce que évidemment
qu'après un scrutin et une réélection
d'emmanuel macron qui est un fait
historique il va faire une analyse du
scrutin il aura une lecture politique de
scrutin et en fonction de ça il nommera
un premier disque est à la fois gérera
les dossiers l'a dit les retraites
l'environnement etc mais aussi donnera
des signaux au peuple français mais bien
sûr qu'il y aura là un signal dans la
personne que vous choisissez dont allah
parcours dans ses compétences maintenant
savoir s'il faut qu'il soit un peu plus
de droite un peu plus de gauche qui rend
dans telle ou telle case je vous dis on
a l'impression que c'est du marketing la
politique c'est convaincre c'est avoir
des convictions c'est aussi avoir une
personnalité et oui ce qui est derrière
tout ça c'est qu'on n'est pas là dans
une question d'ego on n'est pas dans une
question au fond savoir qui a le
meilleur profil la question c'est qui
peut quand même porté non mais c'est pas
une question de personnalité au sens qui
est le meilleur qui vend sera devant les
personnalités en avant la question
sortie a les meilleures compétences qui
peut réunir le pays et surtout qui peut
porter ce projet dont nous pensons
qu'ils apportent aux français et donc
d'ailleurs une majorité de français a
considéré qu'on peut lui faire confiance
des solutions des prairies fleuries l'a
dit hier l'écologie vous savez que ce
premier nazis femme cet homme ou cette
femme aura des responsabilités majeures
sur l'écologie cet homme ou cette femme
aura avéré société hoxha ça sera sur les
personnalités qui sera reconnue pour ses
compétences en matière d'environnement
compétences déjà amené un immense projet
d'organisation à la fois
gouvernementales et du pays dans son
ensemble que les élus donc il faut pas
dans ce match sans traitement étrangers
à l'écologie est le cas cela emparèrent
à julie il faudra que cette personne
soit en particulier très habile dans sa
capacité à concerter parce que vous
savez que ce soit sur l'écologie avec la
planification et le lien avec les élus
locaux que ce soit sur les questions des
retraites ou le coeur de notre projet
c'est de concerter
que ce soit sur l'école ou la santé que
ce soit la réforme des instituts sur
tous ces grands projets du président ou
comme j'ai à dire lui lien commun le
fait que nous ne pouvons pas réussir
seuls nous ne pouvons réussir que si
nous dressons les citoyens participent
et que si nous associons les maires que
si nous associons les chefs
d'entreprises donc c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui aura avec tout le gouvernement
l'immense mission rassembler les
français c'est par un grand mot c'est
comment sur chaque sujet eh bien vous
échangez vous discutez vous concerter
vous créer le consensus d'accord avant
l'ambition qu'un profil effectivement de
concertation locale évidemment qu'ils
portent à la concertation est quand même
aussi un critère sur
l'environnement vous venez me dire
c'était très important la discussion la
concertation ce sera entre guillemets un
marqueur pour employer un mot à la mode
du début du mandat d' emmanuel macron or
ce matin on entendu bruno le maire
répondre à une question sur la fin des
retraités il n'a pas exclu l'usagé le
recours aux 49 3 qu'ils ont c'est une
procédure qui permet entre guillemets de
passer en force est ce que c'est un bon
signal à ce titre lors des justes aura
rembobinez le fils de minutes d'abord un
sur les retraites l'engagement du
président très clair très transparent je
pense qu'il l'a répété des multiples
fois des dizaines de fois dans cette
campagne c'est que cette réforme nous
avons un cap c'est de motivation on va y
revenir tout à leur concert on parle de
la méthode est bien sûr la méthode 49 3
cette question ne se pose pas avant les
élections législatives ont pas eu lieu
donc on sait pas dans quelle majorité
quelle sera la majorité qui sera devant
nous on espère qu'elle sera la plus
large possible et c'est sous le combat
qu'on va mener ensuite on avait un doute
j'ai pas de doute mais voyez-vous me
parlait déjà d'une procédure
parlementaire que les élections les
chattes ils n'ont pas eu lieu ensuite
vous parlez d'un texte qui n'est déjà
pas lui-même sur la table on va mener
une concertation précisément pour bâtir
le consensus le plus large donc pour moi
il ya des questions qui ne se pose pas
et puis au fond pourquoi on parle de ça
parce que jean luc mélenchon fabien
roussel et d'autres sont en train alors
même que voyez les élections
présidentielles ont lieu hier soir déjà
d'expliquer aux français que nous
serions des gens autoritaire qui ne
l'ont pas écoutée qu'elles ont passées
en force donc c'est un piège faisons les
choses dans l'ordre la question a été
posée à bruno le maire
ce qu' il est exclu de recourir aux 49 3
il pas dit non constitution n'est pas
une question avec mélenchon s'étaient
pas une affirmation de marine le pen
présent le maire qui m'a dit la
constitution et s'assurer vous comprenez
que ça ait surpris je comprends mais je
vois surtout que ce sujet n'est pas
arrivé par hasard il est arrivé parce
que déjà oui on est dans un pays comme
très étrange hier soir se passer
l'élection présidentielle une élection
qui est clair une élection qui montrent
qu'il ya une majorité de français qui
donne un mandat un président ce qui le
rend légitime ça nous oblige aussi c'est
ce qu'il a dit oblige la marque porter
des responsabilités d'unité et de porter
un projet c'est une élection qui est
saluée dans le monde et aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression qu'une partie de la classe
politique et c'est pas ma conception est
déjà dans la sinistrose dans les
passions tristes déjà en train
d'expliquer aux français qu'alors que
l'action n'a pas commencé elle serait
comme ci ou comme ça moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il y ait vraiment à
nouveau c'est une forme de fatalité que
certains essayent d'installer dans le
débat c'est qu'au fond les hommes les
femmes politiques l'élection passée
serait à nouveau déjà en train de parler
d'eux de leur parti de leur ego de leur
revanche
respectons le vote des français avaient
trouvé un peu chagrin coup un peu chaque
point et les français non les pas les
français les rayons sa politique à huy
qui tout mauvais joueur alors on avait
perdant si on écoute certains j'ai
l'impression qu'il aurait fallu que l'on
dise qu'on a perdus pour faire plaisir
aux oppositions oui on a vu on a gagné
et il faudrait qu'on est là la victoire
hantz et ça qu'on attende me faut qu'on
les modestes parce que le cirque on s'en
est d'abord internationales nationales
les urgences à résoudre évidemment les
enjeux démocratiques font qu'on va pas
claironner sur tous les toits mais on a
quand même fatigué aujourd'hui une
victoire qui est réel un président qui
est réélu on sait tous les uns les
autres que c'est inhabituel sans
cohabitation qu'intel faits se
produisent dans notre vème république
donc ce que je vais vous dire moi c'est
que mon projet le projet du président
était tout cette majorité vous comprenez
pas parvenir vos biens français ont
constaté qu'il ya pas un énorme
enthousiasme à la réflexion de emmanuel
macron qui fait un score de 58 % qui est
assez confortable mais face à une
candidate qui n'est pas tout à fait
comme le comme une autre marine le pen
qui incarne encore l'extrême droite vous
tous vous êtes un peu dérangée par le
fait que ça manque un peu d'élan moi je
vais vous dire ce qui m'a dérangé depuis
des mois peut-être même depuis des
années c'est que les partis de droite
encore ces derniers jours ont été
extrêmement ambigu sur la manière de
combattre l'extrême rose ou d'ailleurs
de ne rien dire
j'ai été très gêné par eux aussi les
ambiguïtés là aussi la gauche le laisser
faire marine le pen fn qu'on va faire de
son corps qu'elle fait et vous pensez
qu'elle aurait fait quel score s'ils
n'étaient pas emmanuel macron 6 face à
elle elle avait trouvé ces candidats qui
n'auraient pas été capables de la comba
que dans cinq ans donc et bien ce sera
huit mois et un ça traduit quoi sacre à
lui comme l'a dit un résident d'abord un
pays fatigué ça traduit évidemment la
guerre en ukraine créé sur notre pays
notamment une poussée d'inflation qui
crée beaucoup d'angoissé donc c'était et
que nous combattons pied à pied avec des
mesures efficaces et que la héronnière
poursuivre ça traduit évidemment aussi
que nos institutions démocratiques
doivent évoluer plus de participation
avoir un système où les citoyens peu
denses qui notamment concernant vie
quotidienne plus souvent donc des
dysfonctionnements quand même que qui
n'ont pas été résolues pendant cinq ans
et que vous promettez de réseau si vous
prenez le sujet des institutions non on
va pas le prendre maintenant parce qu'on
va y reviendrait tout à l'heure et je
vous promets à essayer c'est promis on a
appris le président a pris des
engagements et on voit bien qu'il faut
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin en
s'organisant pour que ce soit un projet
soutenable appliquée alors très vite
parce que j'aurai qu'on rejoigne vincent
rottiers relève juste après juste ça
nous a pas frappés que les
fonctionnaires finalement ils ont été
assez peu présent dans les sujets de
campagne d'ailleurs le débat mercredi
soir entre emmanuel macron marine le pen
ya pratiquement pas été question ils
n'ont pas été un peu les oubliées
l'avant vos sujets je souris parce que
il ya quelques mois je vivais une
candidate valérie pécresse qui avait
fait tout son programme de campagne tous
au financement de nouveaux projets sur
la réduction des armes et vous savez
deux cent mille fonctionnaires plus 50
me d'ailleurs personne avait très bien
compris ce qui se passait et vous savez
traverse est un solde de 150000 à se
promener avec c'est l'invasion par des
celle de la fameuse rgpp du fameux un
sur deux sur trois qui a eu des effets
délais r sur l'état et nous nous avons
porté un projet de proximité un projet
de transformation et non pas je dire de
vision comptable donc il a bien été
question des fonctionnaires des agents
publics on a aussi porté une revente de
la haute fonction publique qui est un
élément majeur de l'action du président
des cinq dernières années donc on a
parlé de la leur on en a parlé sous un
certain angle et on va rejoindre vincent
roux tout de suite en direct du figaro
live vous êtes là vincent oui absolument
soir elisabeth dans sa cave en soirée
dimanche là vous avez la parole
oui ça a été un des thèmes que l'on a vu
surgir au cours de la campagne surtout à
la faveur du travail qui a été fait par
les parlementaires arnaud bazin eliane
assassi sur le recours au cabinet de
consultants est ce que il faut
s'attendre à ce que vous couriez encore
au cabinet de consultants pour mener les
réformes qui sont souhaitées par
emmanuel macron ou bien est-ce que vous
allez suivre les recommandations de la
commission et diminuer ce recours aux
essais dépenses
contracté auprès des cabinets de
consultants alors je vais vous répondre
mais je tiens à dire que si on a
beaucoup parlé ce travail aussi des
parlementaires et des sénateurs pendant
la campagne c'est d'abord et avant tout
parce que notamment marine le pen a
récupéré ce travail très sérieux je vais
revenir pour nourrir un certain nombre
de mensonges éhontés de manipulation
grossière qu'il a fallu que d'ailleurs
olivier dussopt témoin même dénoncions
dans une conférence de presse
brandissant des chiffres qui n'avait
rien à voir avec la réalité à tout bout
de champ montrons d'ailleurs par ce
biais là que dans la campagne les
fausses informations que ce soit sur ce
sujet sur les vaccins et sur beaucoup
d'autres d'ailleurs domaine polluent au
fond le choix démocratique des français
donc merci aux élections ameline manchar
bien sûr sur le dépôt de questions sur
les débats de fond qui était un débat
d'ailleurs sur lequel nous travaillons
depuis des mois puisque nous avons pris
avec le prêt ministre dès le mois de
janvier des mesures très fortes
d'ailleurs en lien avec la réforme de la
haute fonction publique pour que
désormais nous nous organisions très
strictement pour que nous ne fassions
pas appel au cabinet de conseil dès lors
que nous avons des compétences en
interne après il ya les situations
réalisation après situation on a besoin
de renforts extérieurs quand vous avez
une crise et vous a besoin de renforts
quant à un moment donné vous avez besoin
de compétences très spécifiques dont
vous n'avez pas la ressource en interne
ou alors que vous avez besoin d'un
regard extérieur mais la règle que nous
avons fixées dès le mois de janvier 2022
avec le premier ministre c'est de dire
maintenant que nous avons fait cette
réforme de la haute fonction publique
que nous pouvons mieux organiser nos
ministères mieux organiser nos
compétences nous nous fixons comme
règles strictes pas de recours à des
consultants
sauf un temps que eh bien nous avons des
compétences en interne si a pas les
compétences on peut avoir de retour et à
l'extérieur si on a les compétences et
ben on utilise nos compétences c'est le
progrès vous attendiez et réponses qu'on
atteint en juillet the lady avec olivier
pendant la conférence de presse il ya ce
nombre de préconisations du rapport du
sénat qui nous sommes tout à fait
pertinente et que nous sommes en train
de mettre en oeuvre des clients
notamment tout ce qui a dû très la
déontologie il y avait des propositions
qui sont supplémentaires par rapport aux
décisions du premier ministre du mois de
janvier est donc que nous avons annoncé
que là aussi on va les mettre en oeuvre
très bien merci merci vincent à la
semaine prochaine bien sûr je vous
présente président bush et à mme tran
huy qui vont me poser des questions très
précises sur les dossiers vous aimez la
technique n'allez pas être déçus on
commence par le gène pouvoir d'achat que
savez-vous pourquoi d'atari mieux avoir
des idées bon allez on va dire ça vous
voulez commencer le quinquennat en
faisant voter un paquet de mesures
autour du pouvoir d'achat parmi ces
mesures il ya notamment le chèque
alimentation dont on ne connaît pas bien
les contours alors quelles seront les
caractéristiques à qui ça s'adresse pour
acheter quoi et c'est alors qu'est ce
qu'on cherche à faire c'est au tour du
pouvoir d'achat on cherche d'abord à ce
que le travail paye ça je pourrais
revenir on cherche à s'assurer que les
retraités ne perd pas trop de pouvoir
d'achat face à la hausse de l'inflation
et puis on cherche à limiter la hausse
des dépenses pour se chauffer pour se
déplacer pour s'alimenter d'où le shaq
alimentant de chaque alimentation le but
là c'est de cibler un effort budgétaire
non pas comme le proposait madame le pen
en dix ans la tva 0% pour tout le monde
mais d'aider les ménages les plus
modestes ar c'est qu'il aimait les
ménages les plus modestes ça sera
calibré où je peux pas vous dire ici 6
et 5 10 15 milles français mais les
ménages les plus modestes dont on sait
que les prix alimentaires ont des fortes
répercussions sur le bouclage de fin de
mois qui sont très difficiles et qu'on a
tous entendu pendant cette campagne pour
qu'ils puissent acheter des produits de
qualité des produits frais donc des
produits de qualité les produits seront
fléchés et pars dans l'idée c'est
qu'effectivement cela d'ailleurs bien
aussi contribuer à notre souveraineté
alimentaire c'est que ça fasse à la fois
travailler nos agriculteurs ça travaille
aussi pour l'écologie sans fil des mois
ils feraient français des produits frais
les premiers qualité de l'alimentation
saine et que ses produits qui parfois
d'ailleurs certains s'en prive parce
qu'ils sont trop onéreux ou perçus comme
tels eh bien il ya un chèque
alimentation qui puisse soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat alimentaire et la
qualité alimentaire de ces ménages et de
combien ce chèque alors là aussi je peux
pas vous en donner le montant ça sera
quart numéro de grandeur on avait 10 50
euros pendant ce temps en euros par q
leur foyer pas prêt à mourir malice mais
évidemment que si votre foyer c'est une
famille plus nombreuse il soit pas la
même valeur que si vous êtes une
personne seule ou en couple dans tout ça
va être prêté mais l'objectif c'est quoi
c'est que on a voit bien qu'il ya une
forte hausse de l'inflation sur certains
prix et certains produits que dans ses
produits dont les prix augmentent il ya
les produits alimentaires et qu'on ne
peut pas laisser les français sans
solution madame le pen avait une idée je
pense qu'on avait tous bien compris
qu'il ne fonctionnait pas bon allez
c'est de faire les choses qui
fonctionnent mal juste part dans une
seconde c'est combien de temps c'est ses
50 euros par mois ça va durer jusqu'à la
fin de l'année là aussi il faut qu'on
voit est ce qu'il ya une partie qu'on
veut garder dans le temps parce qu'on
veut potentiellement oui soutenir
justement l'achat de produits de qualité
dans le temps donc il pas facile qui
peut être qu'on veut sur elle il ya là
fassions tout ça mais ça montre vous me
disiez c'est la technique mais la
politique c'est aussi d'être concret de
faire des choses efficace mais on est
invité à vous et d'avancer mesures mais
un an connaît mon intuition les
religions julian normandie il travaille
évidemment notamment que les missions
des solidarités c'est nous demander ce
qu'on fait en ce moment pas tout ce
travail préparatoire là il est en cours
pour qu'on puisse le plus vite possible
le mettre en oeuvre alors vous prévoyez
aussi le triplement de la prime macron
part ça c'est plus clair au niveau du
montant etc mais ce que c'est
satisfaisant qu'elle soit encore et
toujours attribué au bon vouloir des
chefs d'entreprise un step toujours pas
bien sûr est obligatoire
dans le projet du président il ya une
obligation c'est que toute entreprise
qui distribue les dividendes des
actionnaires
organise une forme de dividendes
salariés qui met son nom si on ne
distribue pas de dividendes on n'a pas
du tout le lot blyes déjà je désire que
si toutes les entreprises qui
distribuent des dividendes à leurs
actionnaires distribuer une forme de
dividendes salariés soit par la prime
macro soit par de l'intéressement soit
par de la participation c'est un vrai
gain pour l'agencé avec bourg vu
quasiment toutes les tpe dans la toute
l'année pas du tout parce que la prime
acron la7
justement caractéristique d'être très
simple d'être du coup facilement
déployer dans beaucoup de toutes petites
entreprises mais là on est plein dans le
également regardé depuis maintenant 3
ans 4 euros c'est dans ces petites et
moyennes entreprises d'ailleurs quel a
été le plus souvent actives et donc mais
pas forcément pour un montant maximum
mais le but c'est quoi au lieu de alors
c'est que les entreprises au fond
partagent leurs bénéfices c'est qu'elle
reconnaisse l'engagement des salariés
que ça fasse du pouvoir d'achat du
pouvoir d'achat sans impôt s'en charge
et qui est donc gagnant gagnant et pour
l'entreprise et pour les salariés mais
ça n'est pas du salaire est ce que ça
serait pas une augmentation de salaire
la vraie solution pour pouvoir d'achat
des français je foire aux de bézieux ici
nous le disait le président du medef les
salaires sont trop bas en france mais
moi je prends du coup monsieur roux de
bézieux homos c'est pas le président la
république dans son bureau on et respect
du smic mais il ya beaucoup de français
qui sont pas au smic on n'est pas dans
une économie où les salaires sont
décédés ni sur le bureau du ministre ou
de la milice du travail ni sur le bureau
du président la république donc si le
patronat français considèrent que les
salaires sont trop bas c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que madame isabelle borne
maintenant ma collègue et travaille
depuis des mois à encourager une
négociation branche par branche pour que
les salaires augmentent mais là aussi
revenue qu'est ce qui est juste et
efficace c'est que quand les entreprises
vont bien elles partagent leurs
bénéfices c'est qu'évidemment on est un
geste très fort pour les plus bas
salaires d'où le fait mais elle est en
paix de près une sorte de grenelle des
salaires est ce que vous allez organiser
cette concertation justement pour que
les syndicats tout le monde se bat sur
un ace à organiser elisabeth bornes mène
des négociations branche par bercy
l'hôtellerie restauration par exemple ça
a pris 16% mais ce n'est pas du tout les
bruns et le smic a lui-même augmenté de
près de 6% depuis mois d'octobre un
certain nombre de branches ont négocié
vous n'avez parlé d'un certain nombre
qui ont d'ailleurs eu des accords tout à
fait significatif le travail se poursuit
parce que quand le smic augmente vous
êtes obligés de continuer alors c'est
pour ça dans la fonction publique on va
avoir un immense chantier sur les
rémunérations au 6 mai l'enjeu c'est
croire à nouveau c'est que quand les
entreprises produisent de la valeur et
on a beaucoup de chance parce que notre
pays a envoyé une croissance de 7% ma
dernière et bien les ça partager les
bénéfices voit l'or pur d'achat
augmenter alors justement vous avez
annoncé mais avant la présidentielle un
dégel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires pendant tout le
quinquennat vous étiez contre car en
fait ça a un coût très important pour
l'état et finalement le fonctionnaire se
retrouve assez peu c'est une
augmentation de quelques quelques euros
est ce que finalement vous êtes pas
renier pour des raisons électoralistes
première chose tout le quinquennat s'est
fait avec une inflation faible est dans
une inflation faible le bon outil pour
revaloriser les agents publics c'est pal
pour un disque points à 10 il est là
pour protéger contre une hausse de
l'inflation ouais sainté possible les
salaires sont bas en général je vais
revenir qu'est ce qu'on avait à faire
dans le quinquennat on n'a pas du tout
une austérité salariale on a mis 10
milliards d'euros sur les salaires des
soignants on a revalorisé des métiers
qui étaient parfois oubliés des métiers
féminins pour beaucoup d'entre eux les
jeunes enseignants on a aussi mis le
paquet sur les revalorisations des
salariés les agents publics les plus
modestes et des catégories c'est 1,2
million d'agents ont vu sur la feuille
de paye du 2 janvier 2022 une hausse de
40 à 100 euros mer du nord et à changer
d'avis la alors parce que y'a 5 rezé
inflationniste mais c'est l'inflation
aujourd'hui elle est au plus haut depuis
35 ans 5% près de 5% d'inflation au mois
de mars est le plus haut depuis 35 ans
donc il ya eu une période 2017 2022 où
on a essayé de faire des choses les plus
justes les plus efficaces pour les
agents publics les plus les moins bien
rémunérés pour les métiers qui avaient
été délaissées pour les métiers féminins
pour les métiers la santé pour la
mutuelle ou 600t des fonctionnaires bon
c'est l'heure actuelle il attend ensuite
ce qu'on a dit c'est que à un moment
donné en responsabilité l'inflation
repartant des niveaux inégalés depuis 30
ans nous avons et le président
républicain prémices sont arbitrés qu'on
ne pouvait pas laisser le smic augmenté
les salaires du privé on vient d'en
parler avant
passez alors comment cela se passe à
achat lui des agents publics
augmenter quand on vend lui
rénégociation les concertations des
négociations elles vont avoir lieu elles
ont déjà commencé sur beaucoup de sujets
notamment sur cette réforme des
rémunérations qu'on veut mener en
parallèle et là on parle du dégel et le
calibrage il doit être le fruit d'une
concertation avec les employeurs
territoriaux les maires les présidents
de départements les présents de région
qui on veut dire que ce serait un peu à
la carte où ce sera c'est le même
montant pour tout le monde tout le monde
a donc ça c'est pour ça qu'il faut
considérer concertation sens entière
avec les employeurs hospitalisé pour les
territoriaux l'état ensuite évidemment
il faut qu'on puisse aussi en parle avec
les syndicats que ça une cohérence avec
la réforme des rémunérations convenait
et le président s'y est engagé je
l'avais d'ailleurs largement formulée
fin mars tout cela se produira avant
l'été avant l'été mais pour des
augmentations qui seront officielles en
2023 ou dès la rentrée de septembre à
mai tout ça fait partie la concentration
mais l'inflation est aujourd'hui avant
l'été permet d'observer assure pour
la fin de l'été sur les miens septembre
donc on vous dit avant l'été c'est donc
ses rangs le 21 août sans sa fiche de
paye le fonctionnaire sera augmenté
avant avant la fin c'est via l'annoncé
qu'on allait revalorise servait une
pension à l'été le smic vient
d'augmenter le président a pris un
engagement que les concertations sur le
dégel du point d'indicé se fasse en 2022
je peux en train de faire un travail ce
qui l'a par contre nous engager à plus
moyen terme et pas de manière immédiate
c'est la grande réforme des
rémunérations publiques qui sont
aujourd'hui pas attractive qui sont
excusés déjà du bon indice le ce la cfdt
est prête à demander en tout cas une
hausse de 3 points du déjeuner en fin
d'année ça vous paraît exagéré où c'est
faisable et tous les mois l'inflation
change c'était le risque est de voir
pour cent en mars étaient 4 5% en mars
d'abord moi je veux calibrer les choses
par rapport à la réalité de voir ce qui
se passera à avril mais il faut qu'on
soit extrêmement donc trop criant ça
peut être si ses lames ciel va vous dire
ce qui se passe dans les prochains mois
ensuite notre objectif c'est de protéger
le pouvoir d'achat il ya d'autres
mesures qui ont été prises par ailleurs
pour tous les français donc il faut
qu'on calibre bien des choses que ça
protège le pouvoir d'achat des agents
publics tout comme on protège le pouvoir
d'achat va coûter combien salariés du
privé en ça va coûter combien ça coûte
de leur exemple moi points
dis que ça coûte 2 milliards d'euros
d'accord mais ça mérite et il part de
notre responsabilité d'employeur parce
que je peux vous dire une chose qu
est-ce qui aujourd'hui notre plus grand
défi d'un fonction publique c'est de
recruter des hommes et des femmes pour
des métiers essentiels on le voit
l'hôpital on le voit dans la sécurité ou
l'intérêt de l'enseignement moi j'ai pas
arriver devant les agents publics
l'indiana a coûté vous faites un métier
de sens un métier nécessaire utile à vis
des français mais nous coûter le pouvoir
d'achat
qu'on va parler d'un autre catégorie ou
plutôt une catégorie gratter ce dossier
essentiel l'augmentation de salaire pour
tous les enseignants qu'à premier
emmanuel macron + 10 % de salaire et
plus de salaire en dessous de 2000 euros
nets c'est ce qu'il a dit vous vous le
confirmer je me convient parce que c'est
d'ailleurs le projet pluriannuel qui
était présente et qui a été initiée
pendant le quinquennat qui vient de se
terminer et qui va donc se poursuivre
comme l'a donc ce n'était pas une
annonce c'était déjà répété déjà prévus
c'est en tout cas une annonce qu'on
poursuivre nos engagements c'est
important
et ce cas du président par ailleurs
c'est que nos enseignants aujourd'hui
sont rémunérés sur la base du temps
qu'ils passent devant les élèves sauf
qu'ils font plein de choses que devant
des élèves ils voient les parents ils
ont des projets éducatifs notamment pour
les élèves en difficulté ils font les
devoirs faits au collège après la classe
ils s'engagent dans des projets
pédagogiques innovants dans les
quartiers d'éducation prioritaire ils
sont ils sont valorisés pour ces
fonctions là mais ses fonctions et sont
aussi menées dans beaucoup d'autres
territoires vous savez que c'est là
qu'il ya eu un problème avec les
enseignants quand même lorsque emmanuel
macron a dit que toutes ces missions
devait être valorisés revaloriser les
enseignants ont l'impression qu'ils
allaient avoir une révalorisation
seulement au mérite et pour les
enseignants qui font ça mais le
président l'a dit aujourd'hui quand vous
faites les devoirs faits au collège
quand vous faites du soutien ou à des
élèves défavorisés ou qui ont des
difficultés quand vous passez du temps
avec les parents quand vous participez à
un projet éducatif dans un territoire
aujourd'hui on a une situation qui comme
assez étrange c'est qu'il ya des
endroits de france ou bien vous gagnez
plus sur votre feuille de paye à chaque
feu mois et des endroits que ce n'est
pas le cas et de ce que dit le président
sait qu'à partie moment où les
enseignants s'engagent comme ils le font
dans leur immense majorité déjà dans ses
processus danser dans cette liberté
pédagogique on veut leur donner
d'ailleurs de manière accrue il faut
qu'on puisse mettre du salaire en face
mais pas dans les lycées tribu alors
hausses de salaires mais les + 10 %
c'est pour tout le monde ces
inconditionnels c'est en plus d'accords
sélénium et parfums oui c'est sur le
quinquennat sait comment ça c'est vous
dites c'est énorme et c'est bien ce
qu'on doit en être saignant pour les
chiens avaient largement présent mais
10% c'est sûrement sans vérité quand le
président mais dans son projet 12
milliards d'euros pour l'éducation dont
6 milliards pour les salaires des
enseignants c'est parce qu'on considère
que c'est important et 10 % ces cinq dix
et c'est sur c'est sûr laissé seul à la
suite du grenelle de l'éducation les
engagements qui ont été pris et en plus
il ya ce qu'on veut faire évidemment
pour que cette liberté pédagogique qu'on
donne cet engagement des enseignants
soient valorisés la l'immense majorité
des enseignants aujourd'hui font déjà
tout ça sauf que ça ne se voit pas sur
la feuille de paye et si on veut
revaloriser le métier si on veut aussi
pouvoir différencier les choses oui bien
que une place de primaires dans un
quartier nord de marseille c'est pas
tout à fait la même réalité qu'une école
rurale dans les deux cas il y avait des
filles immense mais il faut qu'on puisse
aussi tu serais de la marge manoeuvre
pour valoriser ce que font nos dents
c'est juste c'est donc c'est pluriannuel
donc c'est dans le budget 2023 pour
l'année prochaine y aura une
revalorisation et ainsi de suite
exactement distribuant c'est qu'il ya
une loi de finances et qui organise les
choses telles que qui sait combien pour
le pour le budget 2023 par exemple je
n'ai pas le chiffre aujourd'hui de vous
dire comment les 12 milliards du projet
du président mais bondit de 12 milliards
doyer d'investissements dans l'éducation
sur cinq ans vous allez retrouver vous
savez les chiffres vrai que l'arrêt
genève 12 à dire que les enseignants etc
nous engageons à parler de pouvoir
d'achat il ya un bouclier tarifaire qui
devrait se prolonger jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 vous prévoyez aussi un
dispositif des aides pour les gros
rouleurs est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quelle forme ça va prendre ça fait
partie du travail qu'on mène
actuellement là aussi pour le bien le
calibre et par rapport au marché mondial
aux réalités de marché vous savez que
les prix y ont baissé de plus que 18
centimes qui était de ce que le
gouvernement a lui mis dans la baisse
des prix donc là aussi on essaye
toujours de faire des choses cible est
juste et efficace parce qu'on a entendu
beaucoup chemin campagne avait des
grands des grands mots des grandes tva
bush en est on sait que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on y arrive donc et qui va payer
là c'est l'employeur ou c'est l'état
l'avait mais encore on a utilisé le
levier de l'indemnité kilométrique ça
c'est sur les feuilles de paye moi même
j'ai revaloriser voyez les barèmes de
frais kilométriques ans et les agents
publics qui utilisent leur voiture donc
on n'a pas d'indicé arrivons à nouveau
la méthode du président sait on utilise
et on déploie ce qui est le plus
efficace parce qu'il ya urgence et je
peux vous dire que dans nos priorités
d'ailleurs pour répondre aussi à
beaucoup d'anxiété d'inquiétude des
français dès l'été et bien les mesures
annoncées vont être prises et iront
l'embellie pour être efficace accordait
le président l'a dit va dire à une loi
un projet doit d'ailleurs
potentiellement exceptionnelles des
congés d'adidas rectificative début
juillet pour que la mesure du poids
d'achat plus appliqué c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que le combat des
législatives est aussi un combat pour
que les mesures que nous préparons
puisse être mise en oeuvre le plus
rapidement possible ce bouclier
tarifaires et l'essentiel est donc
jusqu'à la fin de l'année est gage oui
si toutefois l'inflation continuait vous
vous laissez la possibilité de le
poursuivre en 2023 et notre méthode
c'est quoi c'est de faire des choses
efficace il a encore besoin on continue
ensuite on s'adapte aussi la réalité
note nous sommes c'est quoi c'est que
les français soient protégés on est je
tiens à le rappeler le pays d'europe
avec la plus faible inflation
aujourd'hui si sûr qu'elle est forte
mais avec quatre et demi pour son
inflation c'est pas les 10-12 % qu'on
voit dans certains de nos pays voisins
donc on va continuer mais aussi sur ces
enjeux continue avec notamment la ré
indexation sur l'inflation des pensions
de retraite pourtant vous les aviez
désindexer en 2018 est ce que c'est un
tête à queue politique rappelons les
choses là aussi on va me dire la façon
été faible à l'époque en 2018 19
l'infection était faible elles ont été
ré indexer et donc au 1er janvier 2019
au 1er janvier 2020 au 1er janvier d'une
inter puis 22 c'est pas vraiment la
logique au départ vous disiez les
retraités doivent gagnent bien leur vie
mieux des actifs on avait la nausée
effectivement par un stand de réforme du
début de quinquennat c'est vrai un
effort un stand de retraités aisés pour
qu'ils puissent de classes moyennes et
basses plutôt aisé qu'il puisse
contribuer à l'effort du pays pour
qu'ils du plein emploi parce qu'on sait
que c'est l'emploi qui financent les
retraites
mais là aussi revenons-en à nos
objectifs quand en janvier 2022 des
pensions était augmenté de 1,1 pour cent
c'était l'inflation 2021 ça s'est vu ça
fait 1 1% d'une retraite ça se voit mais
ça fait pas un effet évidemment
monumental là l'inflation est passée on
l'attend en 2022 à 4 24% ce que dit le
président sait qu'on va pas attendre
janvier 2023 pour que la revalorisation
des 84 % arrivent donc on l'anticipait
et vous pourrez refaire une
revalorisation par exemple là encore si
l'inflation se poursuit en janvier
dernier cherche à trois objectifs je
leur dis pas comme ça ça va être très
clair que le travail paye on a parlé
avec dans le privé dans public que les
retraités ne pète pas de pouvoir d'achat
et troisièmement que nous limitions la
hausse des prix contre un en particulier
l'énergie et les prix alimentaires pour
notamment les ménages les plus modestes
alors un autre sujet à celui de
l'environnement on a beaucoup vu
emmanuel macron par les environnements
dans l'entre-deux-tours encore parler de
grande nation
écologique hier hier soir sur le champ
de mars vous vous êtes cassé les dents
sur la taxe carbone là vous vous avez
des engagements notamment à doubler
notre réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sur le quinquennat est ce
qu'on peut vraiment le faire cela sent
aucunement faire de l'écologie punitive
regard des premiers exemples de mesures
écologiques réussi aidé pendant le
quinquennat qui se termine 1,4 million
de ménages à rénover leur maison ces 650
milles seulement sur l'année 2000 vanter
avec des avec des niveaux dead qui sont
bien sûr assez pour l'instant oui
variable est modeste par rapport aux
pays pauvres avocat dr antonio monde et
y travaille vraiment l'isolation
efficace mais également les augmenter
six cent cinquante mille ménages qui
rénovent leur maison 2021 700000 chaque
année en suède à partir de 2022 ça
permet de faire des gains proposition
qui est venu de la gauche a d'ailleurs
c'est une proposition qui on a réussi à
la faire fonctionner grâce à ma prime
raynaud autre exemple le changement de
véhicule
un million de français ont changé de
véhicule de manière aidé et soutenu par
notamment la prime à la conversion
pendant quinquennat nous voulons aller
plus loin en mettant à disposition des
véhicules électriques en location longue
durée en lice easing qui coûte 80 à 90
euros par mois quand on a des petits
revenus c'est une immense bien mais
pourra d'achat mais ce sont
90 100 euros c'est un immense bien pour
la planète parce que c'est des gens qui
souvent prennent beaucoup de kilomètres
et vont pouvoir le faire sans polluer et
en plus en ayant une facture réduite
autre engagement que nous voulons tenir
la décarbonation de l'industrie 1
milliard d'euros qui a été engagée pour
que nous produisions de l'acier que nous
produisions du ciment que nous
produisions ses biens essentiels à toute
l'économie de manière décarbonée donc
oui on peut y arriver et des choses
qu'on a déjà fait quelque chose qu'on va
accélérer on a testé aussi des choses
politiques publiques bah vous essayez
vous ajustez et donc on peut partir plus
fort depuis le début de cette émission a
dépensé des milliards et des milliards
il ya beaucoup de dépenses obtiendrez
les objectifs de 2 3% déficit quand
s'est présentée en 2007 j'étais à la
commission des finances vous en souvenez
j'étais député tout le monde avait des
doutes sur la capacité à tenir nos
engagements budgétaires ben oui où seul
bleu non mais nous sommes pas du tout
nous sommes le premier gouvernement
avoir ramené le déficit sous les 3% nous
sommes sortis de la procédure de déficit
excessif en 2019 déficit de 2,3 pour
cent sept avants locaux vides et donc le
président l'a dit en 2026 on commence à
rembourser la dette et nous ramenons
déficit dans les clous pour la fin du
quinquennat reparlera on
peut le faire deux fois et on peut le
faire de manière binaire des temples une
amérique ville dit il ya chaque année le
déficit qu'on doit tenir et c'est ce
qu'on a fait en 2017 18 19 et les
intérêts et ensuite il ya la dette qu'on
doit rembourser comment la rembourse sa
dette en ayant de la croissance en ayant
du plein emploi en remettant le pays au
travail et on l'a bien vu d'ailleurs en
2021 nous avons déjà réduit notre ratio
de dette sur pib alors nous avons
commencé c est l avait dérapé et la
croisière
il aurait pas plus fallu faire le quoi
qu'il en coûte tous les savants avant
quoi qu'il en coûte non là la dette et
non pas du tout dans les objectifs on
avait passé les 100 %
on va pas refaire le film de doug encore
mais tous les gens qui vous disent
aujourd'hui la main sur le coeur c'est
terrible une dette tous les économistes
ou les experts vous dit ça vous avions
pas fait le poids devant mais moi je
vous parle pas du quoi qu'il en coûte
jeudi avant mais avant nous sommes le
pays qui a ramené le déficit à 2
je vous parlais en 2019 et la dette a
suivi une trajectoire qui est celle d'un
pays qui sortit la procédure de déficit
excessif
je pense sont des gages de crédibilité
de sérieux qu'on va évidemment
poursuivre alors on parle de la réforme
de la de la proportionnelle c'est une
réforme qui nécessitent pas de révision
constitutionnelle vous aviez promis que
vous le feriez et vous ne l'avez pas
fait pourquoi parce que le président
voulait pas juste faire la
proportionnelle il voulait revoir les
méthodes de travail des moyens travail
le rôle du parlement le rôle de la
participation citoyenne et l'a redit
encore ya quelques jours la
proportionnelle mais là le danger la vie
du coup puisque l'oeil repropose de
faire la proportionnelle sans faire la
baisse du nombre des députés où la
restitution d'oeuvres non ça je vais
reprendre là aussi ce qu'il a dit le
président c'est que nous avons une
urgence c'est redonner une voix aux
citoyens remettent la participation
citoyenne dans le système démocratique
pour que notamment l'essai français se
sentent plus impliqués dans nos
décisions qui les concernent
territorialement mais qui concerne aussi
nationalement remède la participation sa
demande de changer les la constitution
et moi ce que j'ai après l'école que des
lettres coincer les deux ponts à
la constitution autrement qu'avec la
main qui tremble c'était je crois dans
mon livre d'histoire quand on exclut
voilà montesquieu donc céli président
c'est que oui nous avons à faire une
réforme des institutions et le faire de
manière constitutionnelle comment en
réunissant de manière nouvelle des
experts des juristes dans un esprit
trans partisan des hommes et des femmes
qui peuvent mais vous faisait attraper
grs terminé avec un blocage du sénat six
mois je ne suis pas de ce camp là de
fatalité non mais vous avez déjà essayé
pendant cinq ans qu'on l'a pas essayer
comme ça on n'a pas essayé avec cette
méthode là non mais là si le président
veut la proportionnelle pourquoi il fait
pas une loi simple et il a introduit la
proposition c'est le sujet c'est pas là
mais c'est qu'on est devant décorrélée
du reste s'il est réputé avec les mêmes
pouvoirs vous savez que je me suis
beaucoup battu à l'époque pour les
pouvoirs notamment d' évaluation et
contrôle les parlementaires c'est
essentiel si vous avez une plus grande
pluralité politique et vous n'avez pas
plus de moyens et de capacité de travail
mais le président ne veut plus baisser
le nombre de députés il a dit que nous
avions à revoir en profondeur il a parlé
du septennat il a parlé du calendrier
les élections légistatives ils habitent
tous ces sujets associés ce sera aussi
la vérifiant transpartisane cela dit on
en parlait je sais quoi c'est une
commission balladur c'est la semaine
l'outil que nous pensons être le seul
viable pour que nous nous heurtions pas
de nouveaux murs qui était le mur
politiques du sénat où vous allez on a
proposé un projet de loi une fois on
nous expliquait qu'il n'avait pas été
étudié puis une deuxième fois il est là
aussi le mur et nous a été
opposée et donc ce que le président sait
que si on veut revoir nos institutions
et que oui nous croyons que la
constitution doit être respectée
contrairement à madame le pen qui avait
des idées trésor antique on situ scène
pour réformer les institutions on doit
faire travailler tout le monde les
sprays la fois de congères qui
travailleront / les conclusions de la
commission c'est ça qui vous fait dire
que le sénat sera exactement l'état
d'esprit de ce que du président pendant
la campagne vous trouverez par des
parties qui s'engageront oui mais vous
voyez à voter oui mais c'est là où il ya
une immense question de responsabilité
hier soir il y en avait déjà à 2017 oui
mais aujourd'hui la situation est que
les partis
républicains parti socialiste les
républicains sont à 7 % constatent eux
mêmes qu'il ya un problème de
fonctionnement démocratique mais
citoyens se détournent élections nous
disent encore sur les plateaux
télévision hier soir que nous devons
réformer notre système institutionnel et
le président dit une chose très simple
c'est typiquement un sujet où peut unir
les français dans un esprit de clan
je vous prends au mot par exemple si
vous faites la proportionnelle vous
voulez ramener de la pluralité à
l'assemblée vous l'a voté cette
proportionnelle vous 10e levée fait une
dissolution et après comme ça vous
appliquez la proportionnelle pendant ce
quinquennat moi j'aime pas la politique
fiction parce qu'en général on fait dire
à la poésie fixe pas d'objectif fixé une
loi que vous comptez faire et on vous
l'avait dit voter et que vous appliquez
directement mais pour mettre en
application ce qu'elle soit dans
l'esprit du travail trans partisan dans
quel sens les institutions vont aller
voler est ce que ce sera d'ailleurs dans
la discussion peut être que ce sera un
élément politique qui sera discuté de
dire on fait cette réforme on l'a vote
et donc elle engage tout de suite sa
mise en oeuvre est importante mais c'est
des choses qui se déroule au en temps
voulu on va pas longtemps une
revendication vous laisserez parle pas
est-ce que ce que les experts se sont
réunis est ce que les groupes politiques
on travaille ensemble est ce que
l'esprit général de cette réforme qui
doit faire consensus qui doit réunir les
français aient posé pas encore
l'impression que ça a complètement
intérêts la ferté théodule qui veulent
pas du tout non c'est la seule manière
d'arriver à ce que ces institutions
auxquelles fait beaucoup beaucoup de
candidats présidentiels ont tourné toute
la campagne puisse être rénovés dans un
esprit de rassemblement des français a
compris alors dans l'esprit dernière
question parlait de meilleure
participation des citoyens la démocratie
vous allez lancer une convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie déjà sur ce
sujet vous quelle est votre position
personnelle est ce que vous êtes
favorable à l'euthanasie est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin que la loi classeur
leonetti personnel pour quoi vous pensez
qu'il faut précisément avoir une
commission une convention citoyens ont
nommé a demandé votre avis notre
personnel ses intérêts chacun à ses
personnages ça veut dire plein de choses
des nazis ça veut dire les soins
palliatifs ça veut dire dans quelles
conditions ça veut dire pour quelle
personne moi je crois que typiquement
sur ces sujets là pour qu'on a besoin
d'une convention citoyenne mais pour
aller dans le détail poids dans la
nuance pour voir ce qu'il avait déjà
piégé
défendent depuis très très longtemps le
droit à l'euthanasie donc ça existe en
tant que telle n'est pas seulement mais
la question de savoir si on fait plus ou
moins trois palettes ce qu'on vous
demande votre avis nous ne neige pas à
vous dire c'est que mon avis éclairé il
doit éclairer par des débats approfondis
c'est ce qu'on a fait vous savez sur la
loi de bioéthique moi je suis très fier
de la bioéthique était voté c'est
pourquoi je suis fier parce qu'on a
réussi précisément dans un esprit avec
beaucoup de travail du comité de
bioéthique au niveau national beaucoup
de consultations d'en faire un projet
qui n'est pas un projet clivant mais un
projet où on a fait consensus sur
beaucoup de questions très compliquées
qui ont été du coup dans cette loi et
que je suis très fier que la majorité
ait pu voter alors on va parler du
concept de la convention citoyenne on se
rappelle qu'un a déjà eu il ya eu la
convention citoyenne sur le climat les
participants ils se sont sentis trahis
parce que la promesse de sans filtre n'a
pas été respecté du coup est ce que là
vous vous engagez vraiment à retenir les
propositions de cette convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie là aussi
aujourd'hui on est noyé le 25 avril le
président a même pas été lu il ya 24
heures il a pris des engagements et moi
je fais confiance au président pour les
tenir pour organiser les choses la
manière la plus la fois pertinente
politiquement utile qui permettent
d'avancer sur les sujets et donc
évidemment que la manière dont on
organisera les débats ce que chacun
s'engage ensuite à faire à appliquer ce
sera discuté à ce moment là une astuce
pour que ça se reproduise pas en fait
pour que personne en une minute qu'on
après en est mais ce qui s'est passé
avec le aussi la manière d'associer les
chambres législatives libres ou travaux
travaux c'était pas le cas pour la
course au soleil mais comment va-t-on
faire pour aller en dame et il ya des
manières de faire il faut qu'on apprenne
sais c'était une innovation politique
majeur d'organiser la convention
citoyenne elle a produit beaucoup choses
très positives il ya effectivement des
points sur lequel il ya eu des tensions
avec des frictions effectivement mais
consiste à organiser des fêtes vous
tiendrez compte des conclusions
puisqu'il puisque vous associez ray
lewis et la manière de faire ce sera
peut-être assez différent de celle d'un
climat sur les crimes a t on apprend et
si le président aulas s'est présentée
sur les français en disant il faut faire
des choses différentes parce que sur
certains sujets on n'a pas réussi à
aller aussi loin qu'on aurait dû ou
qu'on aurait voulu c'est aussi parce que
le cac est là qui sourit sera différent
même si le cap est clair le projet est
clair il ailleurs constituer une
majorité de ce qui a été les 5 à 9 merci
beaucoup origines et et à main pour ces
questions très précises et très
exigeante ans va recevoir extraire dans
un instant peut-être une question un peu
subsidiaire tiens qui nous ramène à la
question des institutions non plus tôt
l'organisation électorale on a quand
même été frappé d'une certaine usure de
ses règles concernant l'élection alors
c'était aussi bien les parrainages que
les temps de parole qui sont hyper
contraignant pour les médias et
seulement les médias audiovisuels la
question du financement aussi est posée
ça s'est il faut changer ça c'est
typiquement je pense des sujets que sept
secondes de travail trans partisan doit
pouvoir regarder je pense que ça serait
suspect voyez qu'un président en
exercice change les règles de manière
unilatérale et les partis d'opposition
seraient les premiers d'ailleurs assez
légitimement à dire vous êtes en train
de faire la tambouille pour que ça vous
avantage mais dans la réforme des
institutions ce que vous citez est fait
débat et nature à discussion et le
président je crois a ouvert énormément
de sujets en disant vous êtes d'accord
pour dire que c est bon ça peu à bout de
souffle il faut voir les avantages et
inconvénients vous savez parfois on
choisit des inconvénients et puis dans
d'autres systèmes en a d'autres donc qui
est donné mais je me mouille pas parce
que ce serait aujourd'hui étrange que
alors même qu'on veut précisément ce
sujet enfin le héros que la question du
financement le caisson du fabricant
sanctionne que les 500 parrainages on
voit bien le cirque pardon pour
l'expression chaque élection
résidentiel et que les temps de parole
c'est tellement contraignant que ça
finit par être absurde c'est que les
trois sujets goût malins sont trois très
bons sujets voilà ce que j'ai pas moi
dans ma tête directement automatiquement
la solution ça c'est vrai je l'avais
dans ma tête directement prend le manque
d'autres auraient pu la voir et complète
on aurait déjà trouvé la solution il
très rare nous a rejoint bonsoir bonsoir
mes soins alors je vais continuer sur
cette conversation là avant de vous
poser la question clé la première vous
êtes pour la banque de la démocratie moi
je suis poule le pluralisme en
démocratie est qu effectivement si les
anges une banque de la démocratie ne
sais pas si c'est une banque démocratie
aujourd'hui il ya un médiateur du crédit
vous savez quand vous n'arrivez pas à
trouver un prêt pour financer une
campagne et ce qui fonctionne et ce qui
ne fonctionne pas je n'ai pas les
éléments pour savoir si on doit par
exemple rendre ce médiateur pour être
plus efficaces ou crime dont il est
beaucoup question du système
effectivement si gisèle et notamment du
mode de scrutin pour les législatives
vous savez que le scrutin à la
proportionnelle même intégral une loi
simple suffit est ce que ça pourrait
être fait avant les législatives
du mois de juin oui je ne crois pas que
ce soit du tout l'esprit dans lequel
nous sommes mariés une autre rumeur qui
court est ce que le président de la
république ne pourrait pas lui soumettre
à référendum en même temps que
l'élection législative à vous l'avez dit
c'est une rumeur dont je n'ai pas
d'information sont peut-être ça aurait
du sens ou pas pour vous de quoi de
faire plusieurs élections le mec en or
de faire un référendum sur le mode de
scrutin en même temps que législatives
on vient de parler wind et des réformes
institutionnelles s'il ya du sens vu ce
qu'on entend c'est sûr on dit quand on
détruit non là dessus mais ce qui a du
sens c'est effectivement qu'on recrée
dans les cinq prochaines années et je ne
sais pas vous dire si c'est dans un mois
dans six mois ou dans un an ou dans cinq
ans mais que dans les cinq prochaines
années nous puissions avoir recréé des
méthodes de travail avec des citoyens
pour qu'ils se sentent plus associés
pour qu'ils participent davantage et
qu'il retrouve la confiance dans un
système qui tient sur un fait qui le
fait majoritaire que quand la majorité
décide eh bien ça crée une autorité
légitime c'est ça le coeur du débat
qu'elles vont nous alors je vous ai
écouté très attentivement dans toutes
les questions que mes consoeurs vous
opposez et j'étais en train de me dire
entre tout ce qui est social pouvoir
d'achat et la réforme des retraites
c'est quoi le 4
du nouveau gouvernement et du président
et de la vision c'est quoi son cap
politique son cap politique c'est doré
de simples un simple très simple d'abord
de répondre aux urgences que ceux qui se
posent dans notre pays quitte à être dix
mois d'enquêté m6 s'est interrogé des
courses à faire tout à l'heure je vais
faire j'ai pas besoin c'est un cadre de
me permettre le travail paye c'est un
cap de croire la valeur travail et de
croire au plein emploi c'est un cap au
site considère que l'écologie est un
projet de société majeur c'est un câble
de considérer que la france va être
forte en europe j'ai beaucoup de caps
tout ça oui bah ça s'appelle
l'indépendance la souveraineté et le
fait que nous avons de l'ambition pour
l'avenir et que non l'avenir ébahis les
faits d'éducation il est fait de santé
et des faits d'écologie on voit que les
reprises de nos ambitions notre cap
c'est unité et ambition de réunir les
français en travaillant en particulier
sur des sujets qui nous unissent vous
avez santé éducation écologie pour un
achat vous avez utilisé le mot aurélien
les français qu'elle est premier
ministre qui aujourd'hui pourrait
qu'être profili doit avoir quel visage
pour réunir ces français justement qui
sont très divisés vous le savez toutes
les études fracture géographique
fracture
autonome fracture sociale fracture dans
tous les sens c'est un premier ministre
qui peut appliquer le projet du
président qui doit donc le en
l'appliquant créer les conditions cette
unité du pays parce que d'autres pays
avancera plutôt que se repliera
rabougrir à edimbourg sera pas et c'est
le choix que le président la guica face
à un profil politique
alors c'est un profit de vous dire
politique très bon gars n'étaient pas
politiques politique ancrée dans les
territoires qui connaît l'état qui peut
réunir les français oui et c'est un
homme et je la trouvais qui peut et bien
travailler à l'avenir de son pays à
l'énergie c'est possible ou pas françois
bâillon mais c'est je vais dire comme
elizabeth banks ce matin qui avait cité
aussi là vous me posez licence est pas
le sujet c'est pas la question c'est pas
à moi de réponse et au président c'est
une prérogative du président moi ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que je sais et
je souhaite mais je le sais que le
président choisira quelqu'un qui aura
cette vocation à porter ce projet parce
que la cohérence qu'on a devant les
français c'est qu'on a porté un projet
donc c'est bien celui là qu'on va mettre
en oeuvre qui puisse porter ce projet en
réunissant les forces politiques les
organisations syndicales les français
eux mêmes par on en a parlé longuement
et que donc en faisant ça bien d'autres
pays avancent que les la situation
s'améliore ce serait violer soit une
femme
je vais pas jouer au jeu du casting ce
soir avec vous parce que c'est le choix
du président et où ça est sûre chez dfa
reste
une seule la vème république je n'ai
déjà joué à ce jeu une fois où je suis
venu vous voir cher elizabeth je vous ai
dit que choisir une femme pour une femme
ça me paraît ne pas être très
respectueux des femmes d'accord donc je
pense que la chaleur est compétente à
l'art est on censé et ma 6ème fois
raisonner comme ça ah ben j'en suis
persuadé c'est comme ça qu'il a réussi
voyageurs un gouvernement d une question
et je pense que nous étions des femmes
compétentes il ya une question alors
vous allez pouvoir donner votre
sentiment et surtout votre votre vision
pour le coup il ya un débat à
l'intérieur de la majorité et qui se
pose pour les législatives de savoir si
vous devez être vous majorité
présidentielle à l'intérieur d'un seul
parti ou si au contraire eh bien vous
devez chacun avoir votre étiquette de
votre parti d'origine en l'occurrence
vous c'est la république en marche paix
dans la d'autres qui sont agir d'autres
qui sont modem d'autres qui sont à venir
et pour moi c'est la question qui est
posée aux français le 12 et 19 juin en
fait c'est une question beaucoup plus
simple qui voulez vous choisir dans
votre territoire pour faire le lien
entre un projet que vous pensez bon pour
votre territoire et l'assemblée or c'est
ce qu'il faut à parti unique ou pas le
président de la république le souhaite
mais moi ce que je vous dis c'est qu'il
faut qu'on soit extrêmement simple et
clair pour les français très transparent
et très jet dire dans la clarté des
choix pour les français comprennent bien
si la personne qui est devant eux les
nouveautés alors est ce que la personne
qui est devant vous et devant eux va oui
ou non contribué à mettre en oeuvre le
projet du président au niveau national
et en faisant le lien avec le territoire
horizons c'est ça qu'on doit aux
français après je les dis en plusieurs
mois et j'y suis très attaché et c'était
l'engagement aussi du président c'est
que les grandes discussions deux parties
je crois intéresse les partis et je
crois que les français s'y intéressent
assez peu ce qu'ils veulent savoir c'est
ce que le président en prenant des
engagements est ce qu'ils vont se
concrétiser dans leur territoire qui est
la meilleure personne pour représenter
au fond animé être reportée unique moi
je suis non je n'ai pas cité la partie
unique ou pas je suis pour une chose
l'éthique est lisible qui permet dit en
français c'est top cette femme va porter
avec loyauté engage sincérité le projet
du président à l'assemblée alors dans
une salle risque est une jolie tigresse
qui s'appelle un parti deux parties
savaient garde atteint des sommets dans
mon parti et les questions d'éthique est
tout ça est en train d'être organisées
pour que les français s'y retrouve et je
vous dis je ne rentrerai pas avec vous
on des discussions qui n'intéresse au
fond pas vraiment les français quand
j'étais vous je peux vous dire dans les
pattes hearts a pas important ce qui est
important car c'est important vous venez
de le dire ce qui est important c'est
qu'on s'organise pour que ces 500 scouts
en 17 élections qui vont avoir lieu ça
sera fixé quand prochainement vous savez
il faut qu'on dépose des candidatures
aux législatives avant le 20 mai donc
c'est pas quelque chose qui va durer des
mois et des mois donc il faut qu'on
s'organise pour que les symboles afin de
dire ça oui je serai du combat des
législatives pour que les faisait une
majorité pour parler projets pardon si
j'aimerais croire à un turc de l'essonne
c'est là que j'ai été élu en 2010 est
d'accord et vous pouvez être élu et
réélu député parce que vous l'avez été
dans cette circonscription et ça ne vous
empêche pas d'être ministre après
bien vous avez remarqué j'avais été élu
député je suis entré au gouvernement les
institutions la constitution ne va pas
changer envoyés entre le 12 et 19 points
et pris au fond qu'est-ce qu'on veut
faire et des gens qui par le troisième
tour oui je récuse cette expression
parce qu'elle viendrait à faire penser
que les législatives sont la suite ou la
revanche d'un deuxième tour d'un premier
tour que certains auraient perdu les
élections législatives ses dessous c'est
une nouvelle élection qui se passe en
fait avec 577 élections différente dans
chaque territoire des hommes et des
femmes qui vont venir dire voilà moi au
parlement je défends tel projet est ce
que je souhaite c'est que dans chaque
territoire de manière extrêmement claire
les français puissent savoir qui est
l'homme ou la femme qui va s'engager à
l'assemblée à faire avancer le projet du
président dans son entièreté en sa
cohérence c'est ça le sujet vous êtes
prêt à accueillir des socialistes dlr d
on a accueilli depuis des mois
françois rebsamen
jean pierre raffarin eric woerth marisol
touraine donc on a accueilli des hommes
deux empires afin de se faire élire à
l'assemblée nationale non je dis juste
oui depuis le début 2007 qu'est ce que
fait le président at il dit les hommes
et les femmes qui veulent soutenir mon
projet faire avancer le pays sont les
bienvenus eh ben on a toujours les mêmes
logiques qu'est ce que vous faites pour
lutter contre l'abstention c'est qu'elle
avait été énorme de l'ordre de 50 % aux
dernières législatives vous en savez
quelque chose qu'est ce qu'on ferait qu
on trouve ben oui pendant la campagne
des présidentielles moi dans mon
territoire que je connais mieux
l'essonne on a fait du porte à porte et
on à sauter des centaines voire des
milliers de porte on a été présent dans
des lieux des changes pas pour faire du
tractage mécanique mais pour échanger
avec les français pour redonner du sens
à l'élection au fond pour remontrer que
mettre un bulletin dans une urne ça a
des conséquences dans sa vie personnelle
ça les conséquences sa vie quotidienne
que ça fait une différence donc ce débat
là j'ai à dire c'est du débat un parent
c'est se mettre à portée d'engueulades
encouragements de débat c'est de sonner
aux portes et et voyez ces échanges ces
centaines d' échanges que j'ai eus oui
en sonnant aux portes ce sont des
échanges qui ensuite vont vous dire ont
amené beaucoup de mes concitoyens a du
coup aller exprimer un choix parfois
pour me soutenir parfois mal mais c'est
comme ça que vit la démocratie il y
avait une règle qui avait été établie au
début du quinquennat du précédent
quinquennat à l'assemblée nationale
c'est de dire qu'à mi-mandat au bout de
deux ans et demi on change de président
de l'assemblée nationale on change de
président de parti on change est ce que
vous êtes favorable à ce que ça soit
instituée
il ya rien d'obligatoire là dedans mais
que les règles que cette majorité
s'étaient donnés soient
réaffirmées et soient respectés que la
major elles n'ont pas été respectés que
la majorité se fixe des règles elles ont
été respectées à mi-mandat lé tous les
mandats ont été remis en question il ya
des élections tous les présidents de
commissions et d'ailleurs ont remis leur
mandat en jeu il ya eu des élections et
des présidents de commission il ya une
présidence de commission qu'avec elles
qui suivait tirer un peu les donc il y
avait des règles ont été respectées
ensuite chaque majorité chaque groupe
sur le sujet de bonnes choses c'est une
très bonne chose d'abord condé un
règlement intérieur de groupe c'est une
très bonne chose que les responsabilités
soient
fonds revalider par ses pairs au sein
d'un groupe politique et c'est une très
bonne chose voyez dans les autres règles
qu'on s'est fixés nous on applique la
parité stricte dans les circonscriptions
à la fois investi est gagnable ce qui
nous a amenés à être un groupe
majoritaire strictement paritaire ce qui
n'avait pas été appliquée par deux
groupes politiques oui c'est très bien
que des règles mais des règles à nouveau
pour servir les français pour faire
vivre nos valeurs et évidemment c'est
bien que les choses soient clarifiées
pour tout le monde au départ pour qu'on
puisse on ait de la visibilité sur les
cinq ans suivant alors à chaque fois
qu'il ya un candidat à la présidence de
la république est près d'être élu et
promet un gouvernement resserré savez
des gouvernements commando avec
seulement 15 ministres paritaire etc
c'est souhaitable ou en fait ce sont des
déclarations qui n'ont pas de sens parce
que c'est pas salon ce qui est
souhaitable c'est que chacun une mission
que chacun les moyens de déployer sa
mission parfois vous avez vu après la
crise du coc vide qui avait des sujets
très spécifiques qui ont amené à ce
qu'il y ait des ministres qu'ils soient
des mises au fond de projet des secrets
d'état des mises et les gains et donc
larchitecture du gouvernement elle
dépend si ce que vous voulez faire et
donc là aussi c'est un choix que le
président promise prennent en fonction
des projets des réformes des
transformations amener de la difficulté
aussi de ses projets de ses réformes et
donc c'est des choix qui mais moi j'ai
pas de théorie après évidemment n'est
pas en train de dire qu'on va nommer un
gouvernement de chopin 70 ministres donc
oui c'est par définition resserré vous
avez été député vous l'avez rappelé vous
serez à nouveau candidate vous l'avais
dit à yves thréard
l'importance du parlement a parfois été
un peu minorés par
emmanuel macron il faut remédier à ça
aussi je pense pas que le parlement
était minoré par une alors je vais le
dire autrement mais le par les gens
pourront donner de la vitesse et le
président les mines auraient alors
indépendamment de ce qui a été fait ce
qu'il faut revaloriser le rôle du
parlement je prendrai les choses un tout
petit peu différemment je pense qu'il
faut redonner des moyens de travail
accrue notamment des moyens d'évaluation
des lois des résultats aux députés et
aux sénateurs ailleurs c'est des sujets
sur lesquels j'avais été très ça ça veut
dire quoi plus de collaborateurs plus de
ces moyens de dévaluation l'accès aux
données le fait qu'on puisse susciter
des études par exemple
d'économistes d'experts indépendants
c'est un peu une tarte à la crème non
mais ça va mais seraient terminés
malheureusement pas noël barrot laurence
à martin et moi même à la commission des
finances avons mis en place un système
qui permet à des chercheurs des
économistes d'éclairer les travaux de la
commission des finances de manière
indépendante c'était une grande
innovation et on verra si on peut rendre
le traduit par le vent le l'encré et
faire le lien que les citoyens à
l'arrière on verra elle met en
permanence si les lois s'appliquent bien
le futur gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez ray par appartiendrait pas
pouvoir du président et du premier
ministre
après cette élection législative et même
avant on verra si c'est le cas merci
beaucoup amélie manche alain on a appris
aussi au cours de cette émission
contraire aller faire ses courses
bonne semaine on se retrouve évidemment
lundi prochain pour audition publique
bonne semaine sur lcp et public sénat
[Musique]